right
I and Brooks being returning officer for
the Torbay constituency at the United I
am Brooks being the returning officer
for the Torbay constituency at the
United Kingdom parliamentary general
election do hereby give notice that the
number of votes recorded for each
candidate in the set in the said
election is as follows
Brewer Deborah Ellen Claire Liberal
Democrats twelve thousand eight hundred
and fifty eight foster Kevin the
Conservative Party candidate twenty
seven thousand one hundred and forty one
[Applause]
McIntyre Tony United Kingdom
Independence Party you kit 1213
[Applause]
Maus Sam green party 652
[Music]
[Applause]
Raybould Paul Andrew Labour Party nine
thousand three hundred and ten
[Applause]
the number of ballot papers rejected was
as follows want of an official mark none
voting for more candidates than voter is
entitled to 17 being unmarked or wholly
void for uncertainty 58 total 75 I do
hereby declare that Kevin Foster is duly
elected as the Member of Parliament for
the tour Basin citrus
well thank you madam chairman I have to
say can I thank the whole team here at
the Riviera Center tonight for what has
been an efficient effective and rather
enjoyable stag night I'm going to say
it's not what I originally planned but
obviously the other woman in my life had
some slightly different plans for the
8th of June this is a great result for
the Conservative Party hearing to obey
an emphatic endorsement of what we've
been doing as a team but after saying
it's also about being humbled there are
still challenges there are still issues
we need to address here in the bay and
this result gives us the encouragement
to do that of course this campaign has
been a slightly overshadowed by what
we've seen happen in both Manchester and
London and brings home how important it
is that we have the right of a democracy
because we can only have a democratic
vote if other people put themselves up
for election and if I'd like to thank my
colleague candidates for the campaign
we've had and also for their the role
they've played and making sure people
could have a free fair debate here in
Torbay
ultimately there was just one candidate
that wouldn't be able to happen and very
grateful to them for it it's only for me
it's about renewing the work we've been
doing to make a difference here into a
brain I'd certainly look forward to
getting back to work first thing on
Monday following what I've got on
Saturday to make it real different and
I'm so grateful to all those who
campaigned by my side in the last few
weeks my agent Andrew Behrend and of
course the soon-to-be mrs. hazel foster
who also managed much of my campaign
this is a great result that shows the
result of when people campaign
positively and focus on issues
throughout the year the type of result
that people of Torbay will give to the
candidate that does that and I'm very
grateful for it but with that the work
starts again on Monday but I would say
it's thank you ever so much to all those
who took part today for those